[Musique]
bonsoir j'espère que tout le monde va
bien à vos mines réjouies je sens que
vous avez encore du temps de cerveau
disponible
imaginons ensemble une situation
totalement improbable
dans laquelle un virus inconnu
extrêmement contagieux se répand sur la
planète
dans une pandémie mondiale et meurtrière
imaginons trois ans après le début de
cette pandémie
que nous ayons enfin trouvé un
médicament
si je vous dis
nous avons découvert un médicament à
qui permet de soigner
90% des malades ou si je vous dis nous
avons trouvé un médicament b qui
malheureusement laisse mourir 10% des
malades
il est fort probable
que votre perception de ces deux
médicaments soit différente et que la
perception que vous avez du médicament a
soit beaucoup plus positive que la
perception que vous avez du médicament b
vous venez d'être victime d'un biais de
cadrage
qui fait que la perception que vous avez
d'une situation
dépend de la manière dont l'information
vous est présenté
vous vous dites ce geste n'est pas très
princier
vous en offusquer vous vous en amuser
mais
si je vous montre ce si
vous voyez le prince william qui fait le
chiffre 3 avec ses mains signifiant que
son troisième enfant est né
le point de vue du photographe
fait que dans la première image la
vérité est invisible
au delà de ce biais de cadrage
notre cerveau produit plus de 180 biais
cognitifs
parmi ces biais cognitif certains
changent notre perception du monde
notamment le biais émotionnel il nous
fait confondre ce que nous ressentons et
la réalité de ce que nous vivons
imaginons vous décidez de faire du
camping sauvage et planter votre tente
dans une forêt la nuit tombe et vous
entendez des bruits un hululement un
craquements de branches
des bruits de plus en plus fort
vous imaginez un danger
ce danger fait qu'au bout d'un moment
vous décidez de quitter la forêt
votre peur à fabriquer le danger ce ne
sont rien d'autre que des bruits d'une
forêt la nuit
si je vous montre cette image
nous allons tous réagir emotionnellement
différemment
certains de par leur histoire de vie ou
d'autres parce qu'ils sont parents vont
imaginer le pire
un drame humain familiale
d'autres peut-être se diront simplement
fait une petite bêtise s'est fait
gronder par son papa et sa maman
ces deux billets le biais de cadrage et
le biais émotionnels sont
particulièrement à l'oeuvre lorsque nous
consommons des images
pourquoi
d'abord parce que la vue est le seul de
notre cinq sens brancher directement par
sur notre cerveau la deuxième raison et
ça vous le vivez c'est que nous sommes
dans une société de l'image
il y a en france 4 chaîne d'information
un record européen
quatre chaînes d'information qui 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 nous abreuve
d'image
des images qui nous émeuvent
des images qui nous choque
des images qui nous attendrissent
nous défilons sur nos smartphones chaque
jour 90 mètre linéaire de contenus
80% de ces contenus sont des images
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux qui
sont des machines à fabriquer de fausses
vérités
des images qui nous montrent la vie plus
joli
plus sympa
plus généreuse
mais nous même ne sommes nous pas des
fabricants de fausses vérités
l'année dernière je suis parti avec ma
femme et ma petite fille de 7 ans en
vacances passé une semaine sur l'île de
ré le deuxième jour nous sommes allés de
la plage et en arrivant j'ai pris cette
photo de la dune puis nous avons passé
la dune et j'ai découvert la plage
sur les réseaux sociaux j'ai publié la
première photo pas la seconde
c'est ce que nous faisons tous mais
finalement ce n'est pas très grave s'il
s'agit d'embellir notre quotidien ou
d'améliorer nos vacances
malheureusement il y à des situations
beaucoup plus dramatique où les vérités
sont invisibles la guerre
la guerre en irak cette photo la
première sur votre droite non votre
gauche
j'y vois un militaire irakien
avec un fusil mitrailleur sur la tempe
et puis la photo du milieu le plan est
plus large j'y vois toujours un
militaire avec un fusil sur la tempe
mais j'y vois aussi un soldat américain
qui lui donne à boire et sur la dernière
photo je ne vois plus qu'un américain
qu'un militaire américain qui donne à
boire à un prisonnier irakien
la vérité est invisible dans cette
dernière image
dans cette première image je vois
mélenchon avec derrière lui un front uni
populaire mais si je des zooms
je m'aperçois qu'il y à une centaine de
personnes qui ont été bien rangés
derrière lui pour donner cette
impression de front
si je vois cette photo nous sommes en
angleterre à londres pendant le coc vide
en haut mais c'est quand même impensable
tous ces gens alors que nous sommes en
plein confinement dans la rue les uns à
côté des autres sans masque si je veux
bien regarder la photo du dessous
ce sont les mêmes ils sont alignés ils
attendent de se faire tester et une
distance de sécurité les sépare
si je regarde la photo du haut
theresa may en pleine campagne pour le
break site elle est entourée de
militants ils sont nombreux si je veux
bien des zooms et ils sont quelques-uns
autour d'elle devant son quart de
campagne
mais mais il ya pire que ça
rappelez-vous nous sommes en 2010 cette
trempe vient d'être élu
c'est sa cérémonie d'investiture
une polémique s'installe entre l'équipe
de trains p des médias américains les
médias américains affirment qu'il y à
beaucoup moins de monde présent à cette
cérémonie
photos à l'appui ils nous font la
démonstration
que lors de l'investiture d'obama la
foule était beaucoup plus dense
et que répond le camp de trappe
dans la bouche de viviane conway qui est
une de ses conseillères elle dit mais
c'est une vérité alternative
qu est ce qu une vérité alternative
c'est une vérité qui ne repose pas sur
les faits
mais sur la foule si nous sommes
nombreux à le croire alors c'est vrai
mais moi même
nous pas en train de vous manipuler
ne suis-je pas en train
de faire des démonstrations avec des
vérités alternative
en titre un anti anti vaccin anti
breakes site
imaginez je vous montre cette photo
j les jeunes à genoux les mains sur le
sur le crâne et gilet jaune à terre
molesté par la police
ces images sont chargées d'émotion et
elle vous rend elles vont vous rendre
très sympathique
ces manifestants mais si je vous montre
cette image
un gendarme frappé par un manifestant
boxeur professionnel
des gendarmes qui aide un manifestant
sur une chaise roulante et là je pourrai
prendre le parti
de la force publique
la vérité se situe entre ces deux
extrêmes si je ne vois pas tout je ne
sais rien
ne nous laissons pas enfermer ne
laissons pas notre libre arbitre
enfermé dans un cadre
gardons notre capacité de discernement
notre capacité
à regarder les choses différemment notre
esprit critique
ne nous laissons pas emporter par des
réactions émotionnelles face aux
événements
réfléchissons
l'intelligence est dans la nuance pas
dans l'outrance
ne laissons pas le cog ito ergo soum je
pense donc je suis hérité du siècle des
lumières
balayé par un je m'émeus donc c'est vrai
improbable
la société a besoin de citoyens éclairés
tous
modestement
contribuer à un monde plus sensée et
moins sensationnel je crois sincèrement
que c'est la condition d'un monde plus
heureux merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]